欢迎收听古爱,我是盛梦公
本集节目由NOR VPN赞助
8月已经是暑假下半场
如果打算趁着夏天的尾巴再冲一波出国
或是已经在规划接下来的中秋国庆
那这份数位清单一定要收下
我们的老朋友NOR VPN已经进化成为
全方位数位安全解决方案
一个APP就可以防堵钓鱼诈骗
阻挡恶意软体与恼人广告
出国旅游时透过一件切换IP跨区比价
常能够搜到更划算的机票饭店
而在机场跟饭店使用公共WiFi
NOR VPN的全程加密連線
可以保護個資跟信用卡資訊
讓人非常的安心
像我自己還會透過它來跨一些
軟體的鎖區跟手遊路
跨區零保物都非常的方便
而且現在NOR VPN不只支援手機平板跟電腦
也支援Smart TV跟Apple Vision Pro
一個帳號最多可以同時使用於十台裝置
不論是在家或是外出都可以靈活使用
下次要透過我們資訊欄的專屬連結
NOR VPN.com.gooay
或是在結帳的時候輸入優惠碼
gooay
立即享有期間限定優惠
購買兩年方案加送四個月
並提供30天退款保證
不滿意都能夠隨時取消零風險嘗試
好那我上次在飛機上面看了一部超讚的電影
本來上集要推薦
但你就不小心忘記了
在這邊跟大家推一下
叫做極限返航
Project Hail Mary
那它是我在華航飛機上面看到的
我真的覺得這部電影是
可能繼星際效應之後
我最喜歡的太空片
應該是這樣子
那當然前面還有
像是整天要被人家救的麥特戴蒙
或是Brad Pitt
他們有拍太空相關的東西
那幾部都還蠻不錯
我對太空題材一向是非常的喜歡
但這一部Project Hail Mary
我甚至可以認為
它已經可以跟Interstellar
算是平起平坐
有一點不同的方向
一個可能比較那種史詩的味道
另外一個就是溫馨跟快樂
並且有一個非常棒的結局
所以反正怎麼樣
我就覺得這是一部
可能是已經好久沒有看到
這麼好看電影的感覺
一定要在節目上面跟大家分享
因為以前我們確實會在節目上面
跟大家推一些書 影片或什麼的
後來的頻率有稍微少一點點
我覺得一開始會想要推東西是因為
你很驚訝就是你跟這麼多茫茫人海的聽眾們
我們這邊大概40幾萬的聽眾
你卻可以找到一些共同的話題
包含像我自己喜歡的一些樂團或是電影
你發現說有些人跟你喜歡的東西一樣
甚至有時候可以去做一些交流
這個是一個非常開心的事情
因為你要在身邊去找到一些知音
其實本身不是這麼容易的事情
何況你是對不特定的大多數人
既然有時候可以分享一些喜好抑或是有些東西其實是透過我的推薦然後讓大喜歡上那更是一個超讚的事情像是我在spotify的歌單下的訂閱數量好像已經快跑到4萬去了吧
那個本身就是一個非常令人開心的事
那再來有一些聽眾也會推薦我一些有趣的東西
像最近在新聞上面比較有曝光的
那個尼谷喵喵還尼谷貓之類的
我稍微看了幾集
還沒有把它看完
但我覺得那是一部很棒的影集
就是蠻北的蠻好笑的
整個那種話題性也是非常的充足
所以你看完會想跟朋友推薦
被董事基金會說什麼
他可能就是類似說會勸誘人家抽菸之類的
我覺得是反過來
雖然他從頭到尾都在抽菸
但是我不覺得有人會看了這個影集之後
然後你會想要去抽菸
反而是你會非常反感抽菸
如果說你說看了什麼東西
會讓我們的年輕的一代會想抽菸的話
我反而覺得是那一些Gangster片
你知道嗎就是整天拍的
台灣很喜歡找那種加酒
或者說類加酒
然後拍一些加酒片
然後在裡面那種抽菸打架什麼的
那個可能真的會讓一些年輕的小朋友
覺得這樣子很帥
可是我覺得像尼古貓貓
你反而是不會因為你看到這個東西
會想要抽菸
你反而會想要戒菸
我們一向是非常推廣戒菸的
我自己本身也是戒菸的
我覺得戒菸是生命中最棒的一個決定
但有時候就是你看到一些作品
被一起的人
他可能是基於某一種善意
想要去推廣他的agenda
可是他使用的方式像這樣子
我覺得就會被人家幹爆
自己還是要有一點那種
商業或是說社群的敏感度
不然有時候真的會弄巧成熟
總之這個極限反映超級推薦大家
有空的話可以去看一下
它好像是今年的三月多上映的
我在飛機上看到
我後來查一下在Amazon Prime Video
因為我老婆在飛機上面
她沒有看到
所以我應該會再跟大家重看一次
真的是超棒的電影
再來跟大家聊一下紅酒
這樣就讓這幾個開頭都變成是
我喜歡的東西的形狀
那不是要跟大家推薦
未成年也不要喝酒什麼的
大家自己要注意
只是跟大家分享一下自己的一些想法
跟因為有些聽眾會好奇
所以就講一下自己的一些研究報告
前面有跟大家分享
是因為那時候有聽眾要我去全聯
看一下什麼酷的東西
那時候是我記得介紹幾個
都是跟Cabonet Sauvignon是比較有關的
有些也是伯根蒂的東西
但是並沒有真的很切入伯根蒂
或是很切入Pinot Noir
但是其實伯根蒂的Pinot Noir
目前可能是我在整個紅酒的涉獵旅途裡面最喜歡的東西
這個就是有那種見仁見智的味道在
就是有些身邊的朋友他也是比較喜歡可能像是波爾多的左岸卡布內non可能味道是比較重一點的葡萄酒精感比較重一點他們比較喜歡像我如果真的要去喝波多左岸的話
我比較喜歡的感覺是怎麼樣
就是他一定要至少要放個10-20年以上
我就是要讓那個
Sediment開始跑出來
要有一些沉澱物
讓那個酒精味跑掉
顏色稍微掉一點
這個時候可能我是相對是可以入口
但他還不是我比較喜歡的一些類別
然後我可能還是比較喜歡
像是黑皮諾、Pinot Noir這樣的一些選擇
只是Pinot Noir它有一個比較大的問題
在那時候沒有辦法
跟大家分享或自己推薦的主因
就是因為我還沒有研究到太廣
那黑皮諾它基本上現在就是一個炒作的核心
如果說可能10、20年前是在炒什麼五大堡
或一些右岸銘裝的話
那現在最核心絕對就是波根蒂的Pinot Noir
那個炒的價格是非常非常的恐怖的
那像波爾多左岸的這幾個銘裝
可能了不起就是在2萬到5萬之間
你就可以買到絕大多數的年份
如果往右岸走的話
稍微的誇張一點
就要說你要去買樂邦
或是你要去買Petrus
價格是貴一些
但它有平T版本
像VCC我覺得還蠻喜歡的
所以基本上我們去看左岸
就會覺得它的價格都是屬於
相對的平一近人
或是說它有蠻多的平T的選項
就要說它二軍或什麼三軍之類的
但是如果你今天是
走到伯根蒂的Pionoa的話
就算是一些什麼村莊級的
可能也可以賣你罵八九千塊
一兩萬塊以上也是蠻常見的
最近米其林他有推葡萄
就是他們除了餐廳之外
他們家也跑去選葡萄酒
當然這個榜單一定是非常見仁見智
我看很多人在那邊狂罵
其實狂罵的我覺得就是
一定是腦子不好使
因為這不是白癡都知道說
九瓶或是十瓶這種東西
一定沒有什麼絕對
那個一定是見仁見智
那了不起你也可以去發你的食品
我們也不知道去幫米其林
或說什麼幫500盤之類的護航
我的意思說就是你這樣很像是
蠻多人都喜歡摘一個草人自己打
打超爽 你們在幹嘛
食品本來就很主觀
你今天你寫10個餐廳
你寫10瓶酒
我也可以他媽吐爆你
這個是沒有意義的事情
但總是我自己稍微看一下
當然他在三顆葡萄裡面
有些我是覺得是遺豬
應該是三顆葡萄
但是他沒有給他三顆
有些我可能覺得是
就相對我認為還好
可是他可能給他一個很好的評價
反正總是稍微參考一下
但是他三顆葡萄裡面
有一個酒莊
我覺得是蠻值得大家去注意的
我不知道法文怎麼唸
H好像不發音
所以法文搞不好念什麼Ruber之類的
但我就念英文Huber Lamy
這個Huber Lamy
因為它可能最貴的酒是Bartamo Haché大概是12-10萬的一個價格可是它有蠻多是落在2000到5000塊之間的這個酒莊我覺得它的東西就是平易近人 而且品質很好
就是你可以用幾千塊的價格
可能就吃到人家幾萬
或甚至十萬以上的一個水準
這個我覺得是三顆葡萄裡面
一個很棒的發現
當然其他的就不用講
其他的我覺得
在我的角度算實至名歸
就像說樂花或是Dauvinet
是我最愛的
再來DRC 遠近馳名
它如果沒有在上面
大家才覺得奇怪
或是Tumbly
這個我本來是沒有這麼熟悉
是看到它上榜之後
我再把它其他的
就是有名的9款
包含說像是William Kelly
平衡高分的9款
都找來試看看
我覺得這個榜單實在蠻不錯的
但因為這個榜單的東西
絕大多數是太恐怖的價格了
所以你就去找那個Huber Lammy就對了
你就可以去嘗到
我覺得很高品質的伯根蒂
他是一個很好的選項
如果說你要更多CP值的選項的話
我們現在就當CP值超人業
可能就是往新世界去找
覺得有蠻多酷的東西
一下子可能自己身邊的朋友推我
我去研究然後我去試的時候
我覺得這真的還蠻不錯
品質好的東西
像是Best Phillips
Burn Cottage
Storm
然後跟有一個酒商朋友推的
Cool Young
我本來以為是什麼韓國人的東西
KOYONG
但是口味是超好的
一個澳洲的Pinot Night
像這幾款他們都是屬於說
大概在一兩千塊
你應該就可以買到他的產品
你可以獲得一個極好的體驗
甚至是你拿去跟人家忙贏的話
說不定人家會以為
那個是幾萬塊的東西
我覺得那個水準是有道德
所以你不一定要用很貴的價格才可以接觸到這些東西
可是因為一開始我是用那種金字塔打法
我都直接去勾金字塔頂端
所以我一直都覺得說
Pitonotar是一個超級有病的種類
就是太誇張
特別是伯根蒂的
價格真的是太恐怖了
如果我去跟大家推這些東西
大家不會覺得說我是在品名
或是說我懂一些口味
大家只會覺得你這個臭敗金的
所以就是直到可能你真的要把金字塔下面都補完之後
才發現其實有蠻多東西
他們真的是非常的優秀
就像那Cubalami
如果你拿去跟人家做盲眼的話
應該也是有機會可以拿到非常高分
真的是很強大的東西
而且它的價格不貴
這是重點
所以當你發現說
你可以用相對平易進人的價格
也可以獲得巨大的滿足的時候
你覺得非常感恩
這個世界上有這麼多的生產者
他們真的是用盡了全力
能夠copy的就copy
能夠學的就學
然後找到適合的風土
適合的土地
即便不是最典型的
以伯甲店來講
他們是用地塊來分
你已經是跑到海外去了
可能在一些人眼中是不正統的
但是他把味道處理得非常好
你真的覺得很感動說
謝謝世界上有這麼多認真的人們
這麼多的農夫
然後把這麼好的東西端到我們的面前
然後讓你可以用幾千塊的東西
想說這完全不輸我喝的某個那種幾萬塊的東西
一樣我們沒有要去可能故意捧櫃的
或是故意捧便宜的去採櫃的
我覺得人家要當那種羅賓漢就是這樣搞
我們只是說就是每個價格代其實都會有很不錯很酷的東西
那只是當然如果你今天走到某些價位以上
以Cabney來講的話大概我覺得三五千以上
邊際效率會快速的遞減
那如果是Pinot Noir的話
大概就是1萬塊到1萬5以上
那可能就會快速地檢
所以在網上是要有愛的
就類似說可能我們不懂
我們的一些伴侶跟配偶
為什麼會買那個包
你自退拿那個紅白油紙袋就可以裝了
你幹嘛要買那個包
不懂的就不懂嘛
懂的人就懂嘛
所以也不用去多做解釋
又疑惑是有些人會去嘴收手錶
反正卡西歐可以看就好
你幹嘛買下錶
或是車子
Vios要四個輪胎
所以你如果真的要去笑別人的興趣的話
是沒有什麼意義的
因為那個就是怎麼講
在每個人的眼中會有他的價值之存在
你去笑別人你覺得別人是笑話
別人其實也覺得某個方面的你是笑話
所以在這邊去曬優越感
其實是一個蠻笨的事情
就顯現得你可能是一個蠻笨的人
所以我會覺得反正就是說
在可能某個價位以上
你去買的東西
它已經不是實用性跟CP值了
它有可能是在買一段歷史
在買一個文化
在買一個感受度
甚至就是在買那個酒標
它光是買那個酒標
它覺得很爽
它買那個LOGO
它高興就好
你為什麼要去幹給人家
對吧 人家有錢花
他覺得這不是錢
他覺得這是小意思
他可以這樣花 這樣花
但是不代表說
某些領域的東西
可能你乍看很貴
好像說只有有錢人可以玩
沒有 其實他有蠻多
平一近人的選項
當你發現這些東西之後
真的會很高興
有點類似說
找到一個還蠻不錯的巷口美食
可能還沒有很多人知道
那就會蠻高興的
所以我後來發現說
這個領域太深太廣
太多東西了
跟我本來想像的不一樣
當然名裝可能就那幾個
所以你要認真花錢跟認真做
一下就會走完
但有趣的是你發現很多新的小的東西
那是還蠻好玩的
但我講新的小的東西
是在講說可能價格也是平易近人的
因為現在有蠻多新一波的炒作
是他們喜歡去炒那些
就是小跟座面積的
那種什麼精品酒莊
那有些炒到真的是
我覺得你不如再多花一點錢
直接去買那種大名裝超貴的酒
都是合理的
反正就是說都會有人喜歡
但其實有很多的選項
對 不小心有點講太多反正總之就是自己有興趣的東西挖掘出一些好玩的東西跟大家分享本身就是一個很快樂的事也不是說什麼對大家有幫助未成年不要喝酒希望喝酒不開車是非常重要的
這邊稍微跟大家分享自己的一個心得
接下來我們來進入市場的話題
這個禮拜的盤還是屬於相對的黏一點
但是你說盤面的氣氛跟狀態有很糟糕嗎
我還是覺得其實這個盤算是蠻不錯的
因為在過去
特別是7月底跌到最深處的時候
我自己本來是預計有可能要等到第四季
或甚至搞不好明年才可以去收復一些失土
因為一瞬間回太多了
直接從高點掉下來掉兩三成
甚至有蠻多朋友是跌了四五成
所以跌掉很多你要跑下去就是非常的困難
但我看其實現在蠻多人都是陸續的在收復失土
所以我覺得大家都是偏貪心
因為你可能本來是以為說年底才有機會收復
然後現在已經收復一半
結果你還嫌這個盤太慢
前面可能反彈的比較兇一點
到最近就是有些東西開始出現盤跌
或者可以軟屌這些的
但同時也是有注意到
像以自己的持股來講
有些就是持續的已經是
站在無日線以上了
就是要蓄勢待發的往上進攻
雖然它可能相對洗一點
就是那種很壞的盤磚幹凍能載
反正只要是今天鎖漲停
可能明天就直接開地再把你殺爆
但如果你沒有一直去追漲停
或是追牆的話
其實還好
就如果你是以爆破段的角度來講
滿多東西是慢慢的墊上去
所以整體來看
試圖是持續的在收復中
所以還是屬於相對樂觀的來看這個盤面
即便可能過去的盤面
跟可能你在四五月的體驗會差很多
因為四五月的體驗就是反正只要是
跑去追漲就就會賺錢
那個盤子非常FOMO的
現在這個盤子沒有那種FOMO的味道在的
就是大家都在互相算計
所以你今天可能追比較兇
那你明天就有機會被修理
可以拉出去的族群是相對少的
但除此之外我覺得這個盤還算是健康
就至少是說
一些我們可能在基本面有看到數字的東西
它真的會長給你看
只是它沒有延續性
然後可能就漲一漲
然後休息
疊一下然後再漲
最後面是慢慢的墊高
這樣的盤面其實我們覺得還是可以接受的
接著我們來聊一下這個禮拜蠻大的一個事件
就是Marvel跟Google搞了一個
客製化半導體的商業協議
合作的範圍是講
任何attached到TPU生態系的產品
包含像是AI Inference Chip
Memory Controller或是NIC
再來Near Memory Computer
這樣的範圍裡面
所以簡單來說
就是除了TPU的Main Chiplet
或者说Mandai以外的其他周围的芯片
可能都是合作的范围
交换条件是Marvel会给Google全赠让他可以用206.8多少钱美元去購買一定比例的股份如果去把它行駛完的話大概是流通股的7%
會讓Google成為Marvel的第五大股東
那investing的做法就是按照營收慢慢的去認
一路走到2033年底
那我們就現在談結論
這個事情就是
代表Google已經是更加
決心要往COT的方向去走
那什麼是COT
Customer Own Tooling
就是他自己會去做晶片裡面
可能比較高單價的部分
不然說像是在晶片的設計跟光照
以及一些關鍵料件的採購
會放在自己的身上
這個你在3661的
我忘記是法蘇位還是股東會
就是最近好像是一兩個禮拜前
他們就有提到
其實客戶都會慢慢的往COT的方向去走
因為對客戶比較有利
可能一開始你會去走Turnkey
就是所謂一戰式的解決方案
是因為你對這個領域還沒有很熟悉
你還沒有投入資源
可能就會走所謂的Turnkey的解決方案
這個解決方案就是像以前跟Blockon合作
就是這樣子
可能Google就是開一些spec跟一些規格
還有他想要達到的目的
那就由專業的設計夥伴
像是Broadcom
他就會做晶片的設計
然後包含說HBM的採購
基板 封裝
還有相關的料件
甚至是Horex Solution
他可能都會幫忙你
他就去賺取裡面的服務費用
還有包含說去幫你偷片的
整體加總的一個費用
這樣子其實是站在Broadcom的角度來說
是非常賺錢的一門生意
如果今天是往COT的方向去走的話
代表Google可能會開始把一些相對高單價的東西
拿到自己的手上
我們就拿MTK跟他的合作案例
就是V8V9 ZebraFish跟HomuFish的合作方案來看的話
MTK就是提供了IO跟Sertius Memory Interface
然後可能幫忙他去做封裝頭片這一部分
就是以這個V8V9來講
後面是往Intel的方向去走
這個可能就是MTK做處理
但是主晶片是由Google自己去做
站在Google的角度
這個是一個比較省錢的方案
他的廠商像是MediaTag
或是之後未來的一些潛在的Player
像是Marvel
他甚至是直接就告訴你說
你可能可以賺多少錢
這都算好了
所以以這些像是晶片設計業者
Marvel或是MTK來講
他們就是去收NRE IP授權
或是一些設計服務的費用
跟本來像Brockong這種Turnkey
就是一戰式
他可以在每個料件上面都去做加價
或是說因為我包的東西是比較多
所以我裡面怎麼樣塞
你可能也不是特別清楚
反正我就直接給你一個總價
比起來你賺到的毛利
應該會相當程度的被壓縮但是這個其實不應該會是解釋成為說是IC設計的一個有些人會特別是最近盤面可能不好就把它視為是一個壞消息
因為可能多一個人來競爭
我不這麼覺得
因為首先我們要先看說
MARVIL他可能拿下了什麼晶片
當然這個東西可能就不一定會是在公開資訊大家看來到的東西
我們之前有跟大家聊到說
MARVIL有像是MPU
然後還有一些在Google這邊拿到的
包含像之前的CPU等等的
然後還有最近有傳出說Frozen
Frozen這個晶片就我們的考察
當然這可能就是公開資訊不一定有的東西
所以反正就大家聽聽就好
這顆晶片應該說用在Search Engine上面
也就是Google的像是AI Overview裡面的
一些那種特殊化的應用
就是專門for AI Overview之類的
搜尋引擎的功能去做使用的一個
特殊應用晶片
像這個晶片
就我們目前了解到它的量不會太大
大概就是Million左右的一個量
我們自己還有去了解到像是它有幾個代號
可能在MPO這邊有一個晶片
還有一個Inference Chip
然後在CPU好像又額外會有一顆
但這些東西它全部都不是
就是過往我們可能跟大家聊到說
TPU的V8 V9
在MTK這邊什麼
Zebra
Homu
然後在Brakon這邊什麼
TriggerFish
Merope
然後或者是後來傳出來的WellFish
為什麼叫Well
因為它是兩顆晶片拼成一顆
因為像是學蘋果的一個解方
它都不是Fish系列的
就是它不是V8 V9 V10的一個主晶片
它都比較偏向是一些輔助用在旁邊的晶片
所以有些人把它解釋成為是
可能像MTK的一個利空
我是覺得蠻奇怪的
因為它並沒有直接去搶到MTK
或是說Blockhound他們既有roll map裡面的一些東西
但是如果你今天用擦邊球的方式去解釋的話
我覺得還算可以理解
什麼意思呢
因為可能本來大家假設
Google的合作夥伴就是Blockhound
然後後來多了一個MTK
Google我們都知道說它後面還會再開很多晶片
所以可能本來大家想像是
這些晶片都會是有Block Kong跟MediaTag去分掉
現在額外殺出一個Muriel
跟SemiAnalysis提到說
甚至連AMD都要加入競爭
AMD應該不會是去搞TPU那一段
應該就是反正走到越後面的代數
就隨著Google的設計團隊越來越強之後
他們走COT的模式
就可能會把一些類似CPU的
有機會會讓AMD的一些IP一起進來
所以可能市場在傳的謠言是這一段
那你就可以想象成是
它並不是直接對既有玩家的一個掠奪
而是大家可能本來想像
未來的市場是由這些既有玩家去拿
那只是現在又多了一個Marvel
然後又多了一個AMD
大家都知道說其實MTK他也只有做CPU的一個能力
所以未來可能一些本來大家去意營的市場
即便根本就沒有被證實過
但就不見了
所以就藉由這個東西作為一個短線殺盤的題材
但我還是覺得就是因為最近的盤子大家都在回
幾乎很多的股票都在回
所以其實好像不用去刻意的去解釋說
是不是因為這個原因在跌
但這個事件確實可以拿來當成是博通的利空
我覺得是OK
如果你要拿來當其他IC Design Partners的利空
有點像他說他是跳一步去想
你未來可能的市場就少了一點
但有時候市場會太過專注短期的東西
他會忘記說
其實就算我沒有全部都給你
我只是給你其中一塊
你就可以賺到死掉
那個東西都會持續的去放量
所以除了博通以外的其他人
我會覺得說有可能是反應太多
但如果是博通的話
還算可以理解為什麼
因為在過去幾次的電話會議裡面
Huck都是有提到說
包含那時候甚至講說他們什麼Encore biters
就是說這些都是小朋友
好像什麼四星或是發歌
因為那時候都有在傳說
他們可能在Google上面拿到什麼東西
創意之類的
這些他都認為是小朋友
你根本就沒有辦法來競爭
因為我們有強大的IP
跟強大的設計實力
但現在看起來就是
即便你可能有這樣子的一個實力
但是大老闆出錢的Google
他很明顯
他雖然沒有把
可能本來是在Avago這邊的
像什麼Rowfish 或什麼Merope
或者是Triggerfish給別人
但是他把未來的一些路線
已經畫出來了
就是他應該會更加加強的往
COT的方向去走
以前是Semi-COT
就是半個啦
他可能就是去做Mandine這邊
其他東西交給MTK去處理
在TPU的V7或V8
這邊就是已經開始去
把它分成兩條路線去走
後面走到Full COT的話
就是Google會有它完整的光照
然後跟甚至頭片下單它會自己去做
但是我還是覺得
它應該還是會跟一些設計夥伴保持密切的關係
因為在TSMC這邊
確實它的產能是比較難拿到
當然我們不知道等到這一波的循環走到後期會長什麼樣子
可以現階段來講
這些IC Design Partner
包含像之前的L-Chip
為什麼會有一些客戶找到下單
除了他們有卓越的一些設計能力之外
再來就是他們有卡到一些產能
所以還是有可能會為了產能
所以他就會去找各路的夥伴去做嘗試並不會完全的所有東西都拉回來是在自己這邊去做下單但夥伴這邊應該在後期會越來越偏向去走就是COT的路線也就是他們最主要的收入可能會是NRE IP授權
然後這些設計服務的費用
這個應該是Google要去推的路線
所以甚至你可以想像成
剛才我們第一階段的解法是
因為大家都往疊的方向去看
就是說可能因為多了MARVIA
或未來的AMD
讓大家的TAM相對的變小了
因為多為一個競爭者
但你不如也可以想成是說
Google現在真的非常有動機
跟看起來已經是敘事待發
要去開更多的案子
因為就我們這邊看到
Mario拿到的東西
並不是從別人上要搶到的
而是都是新的案子
所以你也不排除
他有可能會在硬體這邊
特別是我們過去有一集有聊到說
Google現在是很認真的
往硬體租賃的方向去衝
也有可能是巴菲特投資他的主因
從本來充滿很多不確定性的
Frontier Model House
然後現在變成是
他也是有在做Frontier Model
他的Flash做的還蠻不錯的
雖然他的3.5難產
但是他在伺服器的租賃這方面
雲端的租賃跟AI的Token產生上
可能會是一個非常賺錢的存在
所以當他把更多資源丟到這邊
說不定他後面晶片是越開越多
然後COT的方案是越搞越多
所以其實其他的設計夥伴都會是受惠的
但確實在博通這邊就會產生一個
因為他本來的生意模式太美好了
它的HBM也是加價賣的
現在就看得出來說
Google是有意識的
要把方向往另外一個方向去推
當然還是不排除
可能會有一些強大的晶片
它會讓博通去做
只是可能大家本來想像
博通可以拿就叫做5個案子
現在5個案子裡面可能有2、3個
它要選擇用COT的方式去推的話
TurntKey的一個總體的量就變少了
所以我覺得博通
你會稍微往一個負面的方向去解釋
是還算OK的
但其他的IC Partner我就覺得
應該會算是一個比較利多
因為大家會想像成說
Google都這樣做的話
會不會後面也會越來越多的機會
會跑出來
所以從一個
本來他去笑別人是
Ankle biters
只是小朋友跟在後面
就像他這些小朋友
因為在大老闆想要去尊傑的一個背景之下
有可能就會分到蠻多的案子
因為這些案子
其實你就算要去丟給Broadcom做
你也不確定人家會不會要做
你知道其實博通這邊是很酷的
Wi-Fi對他來講
搞不好都是一個他想丟出去的東西
可是Wi-Fi對很多台系常常來講是一個
這個很賺錢我要我們知道博通他會去把一些毛利數字不好的東西砍掉如果說未來的玩法是變成是當Google這邊是掌握了絕大多數價值鏈的環節
其他東西他包給你
他甚至直接告訴你說你能賺多少錢
他都是算好的
類似說我們有時候會看到台系的一些供應鏈
特別是那種比較末端的零組件
大家就會知道
你能夠賺多少錢其實是客戶決定的
就算你想要去漲客戶
那客戶還可以告訴你說我不給你漲
那你真的就沒有辦法漲他
除非說你缺到爆炸
你才會抵去跟他按下
不然你會怕說會不會之後被修理之類的
我覺得就會慢慢往那個方向去走
但如果今天在晶片的生產需求上面
還是非常強勁的話
其實也不用擔心說這些Design Houses
會被Google無條件的壓榨
因為你不做它的
你搞不好還有很多選項
就類似後來有一些廠商就是
我選擇不要做蘋果的東西
我去做別人的
我可以不要做
我還是有很多選項
我可以賺錢
所以你的議價權就還是會在自己的身上
所以就我們的觀察會
認為這個事件應該是普遍的IC design的一個利多
Brockham他也是一個IC design
只是很明顯就是在他身上有機會被想像成為說他肉會被敲掉
所以會就是說稍微的受到一些影響
這個可能是還蠻合理的
簡單的跟大家分享一下
接下來我們進入Q的部分
第一位Tiger 孟公 您好
最近在辦離婚
對方明明有錢卻什麼都抠門
小孩的教育費 扶養費 斤斤計較 怎麼樣都談不懂
小氣的人真的很難相處
有时候真想不如归去
幸好我的姐姐会听我诉苦
陪我聊天
我才到现在都还好好的
那希望观音老大可以保佑我离婚
可以在明年1月底前完成
如果达成我会捐3000美元
到SanJude儿童医院
它是让癌症儿童患者
免费治疗的医院
那还有希望梦工
祝我姐姐高雄顶三街美女
8月30号生日快乐
我们祝姐姐生日快乐
不是啊
我是觉得如果今天是走到离婚的话
互相针锋相对
然后跟斤斤计较
是蛮合理的一件事情
我觉得是这样子
我並不是說什麼我鼓勵每個人當call門的人
特別是我很常在節目上都是鼓勵大家要稍微的大方一點
要對家人好一點
但離婚就是怎麼講
就一定是互相去接窗疤啦
一定是互相傷害啦
所以就是會想要去喊各種條件吧
他可能也覺得說
媽的你明明也會賺錢
為什麼我要付這麼多
他不一定是要對小孩call啦
他是要讓你難受啦
所以你就是要扛住這一切的壓力
那希望你可以談到一個好的deal
但確實按照我們自己
或是說在我自己是沒有啦
在我身邊看到離婚的案例
很少離婚是好去好散的啦
一定都是互弄
然後覺得說罵對方這麼小氣什麼小孩幹不給我看或什麼的就是一定都是會有很多的糾結所以我有時候覺得感情也是這個蠻複雜的一種東西
愛的時候就是什麼都可以
好談
那一切都願意給你
那今天不愛的時候
就是會甚至會比仇人還更狠
即便你們曾經愛過
但總之我就希望大家都可以
順利的找到適合的另外一半
如果找不到的話
單身其實也是蠻快樂
希望一位
Den Chen第一次留言
从第一集疯狂咳嗽
每集准时收听的iPhone
感谢孟宫取尬这几年的分享
从大学之董存金融股
看现金殖利率
经您分享开始研究大盘ETF个股
虽然没有爆发
但每年稳定成长已经很满足了
那可以请您分享三个
最近健身最喜欢的动作吗
前几集听您分享
睽違三年做了空手的
罗马尼亚分腿蹲
累炸比深蹲100kg还抖
健身八年
但考量时间效率也都以三项
搭配一些器材为主
有种纯粹的运动感受
那触碰碰搭飞机都不会delay
功能教练学生爆满
我也希望我的教练学生爆满
这是一个非常nice的人
那三个最近健身喜欢的动作
我蛮喜欢有一个是使用TRX
然后接着呢
你先把手撑直
然后再往后踏个两步到三步
踏越多步会越难
那接着呢
脚尖往前指
然後就做出那種我是Superman那種感覺
左手往你的髖去收
然後右手伸出去把自己的身體撐住
然後接著再來換邊
就是一伸一收
然後腳尖要去蹬
這個動作我覺得非常的舒坦
再來第二個喜歡的
我覺得任何有保加利亞帶的東西我都蠻喜歡
雖然我現在聽到保加利亞就會害怕
我後來才懂
因為在重訓或是說健身界有一個說法
就是類似我生於苗栗
然後死於保加利亞之類
就是蠻多人都死在保加利亞
就是保加利亞相關的動作都超難超硬的
但確實是一開始非常困難
可是當你抓到一些訣竅之後
那個滿足感極大
而且你會非常有感
你的身體變得很韌
就是很有韌性
另外一個雖然排在最後面
但它也有可能
其實是我最愛的
叫做Ninja Flow
對啦應該是叫Ninja Flow
或是有些人把它稱為是Stick Mobility
它就是拿一個長棍
去做支點跟阻力
然後去伸展你的胸口
大腿 臀部 寬跟背
全部都會拉到
而且這個動作
我也開始看我教練做
我想說怎麼會有人可以做得這麼優美
後來自己
慢慢的身體拉開之後
我自己做
有時候我自己看
我都想對自己靠你知道嗎
哇靠原來我可以把身體拉成這樣
就覺得蠻好看的
雖然這樣講有點怪
但反正總之就是Ninja Flow
我很喜歡可以去找一根棍子
我那時候在八里島健身房
就是因為它沒有Ninja Flow
專門用的那種棍子
就是橘色然後兩端是黑色
它只有一個像是竹竿的東西
粗的
我不確定那個是拿來幹嘛的
但可以拿來做Ninja Flow
所以只要一根棍子應該都可以搞
所以我大概就最喜欢这三种类型的东西
非常感谢你的祝福
下面一位
MS Young
拜托拜托孟公祛卡念道
我希望来得及
同事离职前被念到
我事务所的同事挂号
他的代号是202
非常仰慕您
我们也因为这两年有听古埃及摸
有不少的共同话题
非常感恩
最近同事202下定决心要辞掉律师的工作
变全职投资人了
年轻打算拼一把
我知道这个选择需要非常大的勇气
希望他能够听到这个留言
我们祝福他一切顺利
也希望大家能够分享一些
转成全职投资人的入门建议
感恩感恩
我们身边有一些律师
转成全职投资人
还有一个朋友是所长
他也是所长
然后变成是全职投资人
我觉得可能律师的训练
让我注意到这些人
他们有一个共通点
就是他们非常会追根究底
在研究方面都非常强大
在人肉方面也非常的强大
然后在各项
就是需要去考究数字的东西
其實敏感度都是非常的高
希望它可以全職順利
全職要注意什麼東西
其實就是它變成是另外一種工作
你不要以為說什麼在家弄股票
就等於是相對輕鬆
不用上班被狗幹
沒有你就變成是被市場幹
然後再來就是你上班被狗幹
可是至少你知道你一定會拿到錢
可是就在說在7月這樣子一路跌
如果跌到8月跌到9月
我就會去那個建商門口幫忙舉牌子
就是你還是要有收入怎麼辦
市場每天在跌
你又捨不得把東西賣出來
這時候就會覺得心裡很難受
所以所有的成敗都在自己的身上
有時候就算你已經用盡了一切
你已經發出了你的洪荒之力
可是盤不好你就是變不出東西
除非你是做一些那種量化Hedging的
可能還是可以穩定的搞一些錢出來
但相對的那個爆發力就會小一點
所以它就會變成是一個怎麼講
甚至我也覺得心理壓力
一定是比你在外面上班來的更大
就是不同種壓力
一種可能是要處理人與人之間事情
然後這些鳥事或什麼的
然後現在就知道說每件事情其實都是很關鍵因為都是直接影響到你的工作可是那個壓力是非常龐大的但總之你一定會換來一個更加自由跟彈性的時間這是肯定的
你不用那邊朝九晚五之類的
然後不用為了客戶跑案子
你所有東西都是為了自己
所以一定是會
如果你是很重視個人時間價值的話
你應該會蠻喜歡的
那希望你可以打出不錯的績效
可以養活全家人
希望一些順利
下面一位
Han Lee C
猛攻大有追踪ADA8ZZ的IG嗎?
沒有
下面一位
Timmy007
我女友說昨天夢了這週最好的夢
就是夢見雨
那是一個粉絲見面會
見面會上的你很害羞
他是你的忠實粉絲安
那另外紅顏路比
是他唯一給我購買的遊戲
但卡關的蛋殼怪
實在是有從回而時的回憶
那最後希望旅遊順利愉快
非常感謝Timmy007
非常感謝女友的支持
對啦我其實是一個
算這樣講有點怪
比較害羞比較內向的人
以前我一直都以為
我是一個外向的人
然後後來才發現
那可能是為了融入的一種做法
因為當我自己有自己的彈性時間之後
就是所謂的出了社會之後
我就盡量能夠不跟人家見面
就不跟人家見面
就越來越索權
所以就真正的認識自己
原來以前就是你可能會
沒有辦法在一個安靜的房間裡面
你就想講一點笑話
你要逗大家笑或什麼的
然後現在就是連演都不演了
就說沒關係
反正你尷尬
我是不怕尷尬
所以我可以跟你對看
我都沒有關係
就是那種比較尷尬比較相對害羞的人
然後再來講說卡關在蛋殼怪
其實蛋殼怪還蠻好打的
你只要掌握他那個蛋殼是怎麼樣射出
因為他慢慢聚攏聚攏
然後晚上噴
他每次噴你就翻滾
你就疊疊疊
然後疊滿就插他
所以應該是相對好打的一個王
他的招數都是蠻有pattern在
就很容易可以辨識出來
下面一位
光
孟公去嘎最近身旁的好朋友
一个一个结婚交女友
剩下我一个人孤苦伶仃
有点落寞
这样的我身心是否健康
心情真的是低到谷底
越来越自闭对自己没有信心
请问我该如何是好
有点濒临边缘
一个蛮北南的做法
就是你等个两三年之后
然后你就会发现说
你变成是身边朋友
可能最羡慕的那一个人
就是当然他们如果是刚交往
刚结婚一定都是非常浪漫
非常高兴
然后接着呢
你知道關係最終其實就是兩個人要相處
那個愛是
我相信是可以維持一輩子
但那種熱情的愛
它一定會慢慢的消滅掉就是會變成是柴米原醬醋茶這樣子所以最終感情就是兩個人的相處那很遺憾的是其實蠻多人都只是這個信氣結合的時候是很順利
要熱戀的時候是很簡單
但是要走到生活呢
那個誰唱過
相處太難
就相處真的就是比較難
所以到時候你就會發現說
身為單身的你
會是大家羨慕的一個對象
你現在要羨慕他們
到時候變成他們羨慕你
但如果說你真的是跟那個
陳小春一樣
就是你不想要一個人孤苦伶仃
好想要交女朋友的話
我覺得就是要去脫離一些自己舒適的圈子
因為你舒適的圈子代表你長期待的圈子
理論上如果這邊有你喜歡的人
或是你想要去追的對象
你早就都試過了
要嘛是沒有
要嘛就是沒有人喜歡你
可是你要知道
這個世界上有80億人
所以就算只有一%的人喜歡你
那也是超級恐怖的數字
所以你要做的是多去曝光在各式各样的地方
多去走一走
去走一些平常不会经过的路
去一些平常不会去的店
有时候觉得不小心的遇到真爱
我是觉得这样子
希望你可以顺利
下面一位
矿坑里的金丝雀
梦工大大
我是癌症四期饶舌歌手
同时也是麦克风装返就开始听的
骨灰集听众
每一集我都有听
有时候会笔记
您的节目帮助我可以不用工作
专心抗癌
获益良多
最近莫德纳因为MRNA个人疫苗
有重大突破骨架爆棚
想問問你的看法
真的很希望有一天能夠受灰
但感覺還很遙遠
不知道我能不能活著
或是等到什麼途徑去加入臨床試驗
希望這個兄弟可以盡快找到適合自己的療法
或是一些
怎麼講
後來就發現說自己身邊有些朋友遇到
癌症的挑戰的時候
然後他們就會花蠻多錢去做一些
那叫什麼標靶嗎還是什麼
反正就是會去找一些客製化的醫療方案
希望你可以順利的找到
如果說可能沒有預算
或是排不到的話
希望也可以儘快的有好的療法
可以找到你
然後讓你去治療
然後你說莫德納有什麼看法
沒有什麼特別的看法
新藥股我一直都是覺得是
非常難做的一個族群
就是你現在看到它噴你去追
你有可能會被修理
因為以前我就曾經在2018年的時候
當時我也是搞新藥股
然後搞到我的AUM
有很大一部分都丟到裡面去
然後最後面跟我想的不一樣
我壓的東西其實臨床有過關
解盲什麼都是順利的
也成功上市
他最後沒有賣好
怎麼會知道沒有賣好
想說這不是超缺的藥嗎
不是市場上同個tier的東西
根本就沒有多少嗎最後面他沒有賣好所以我從那之後我再來去看自己或說身邊朋友去做的一些生技股我就有不一樣的感受特別是看了幾輪之後
你注意到其實從那時候什麼
勇士天國一揮
還記得這個都是已經
現在算老股民了
你至少都有四五年以上的經歷了
然後後來反正就有蠻多
各種生技股都有跑出來
好像現在就是藥滑藥
還是相對是非常的硬挺
蠻多曾經起來的
後來又在掉了血
所以他真的相對難做
就是我覺得比起什麼科技股
或者傳產很難掌握
沒有辦法去給出太多的評價
之前也會有蠻多聽眾
問我神技股
就說這個沒有辦法
因為他甚至是我曾經受過傷的東西
我也不打算去了解為什麼
我想一位
Bonnie 夢公 嗨 嗨 嗨 嗨 嗨 嗨 嗨
上次在路上問你推薦的診所
目前我女兒已經好多了 愛您
另外想要推薦你打高爾夫
高爾夫注重的是平靜的心靈
和對身體精準的掌控
而且高爾夫是一項沒有辦法用金錢砸到畢業的運動
貴的裝備不一定上手
每次擊球打到甜蜜點的回饋感真的會多巴胺爆發
強烈推薦孟公子跟他一起來打
希望哪天可以在練習場與你相遇
如果你要這則留言
這集的emoji可以放顆高爾夫國嶺嗎
這位聽眾我認識
在我們林口文化山路二段跟中山路的交口有遇到他
髮型我記得是非常的漂白的地方爸爸
跟著他女兒
然後蠻神奇的說
我可以問你一個問題嗎
我想說不會是要問我股票的吧
他說請問小朋友診所要去哪看
我想說這個蠻有創意的
然後我跟我老婆就很認真回答他
女兒沒事就好
希望後面一切平安順利
然後再來講說高爾夫球
確實有蠻多朋友都在推高爾夫球
但是我對高爾夫球
相對沒有那麼喜歡一點
就是他要在那邊
我看我朋友去打都是一整天
然後在那邊曬太陽
但如果今天只是去練習場打的話
我可能覺得就還好
就練習場去那邊亂揮球
應該是沒有問題
因為大學的時候
那時候體育就要去選東西上
我記得那時候好像選兩種
我就有選過高爾夫
我覺得蠻好玩的
真的是蠻好玩
如果你只要打球就蠻好玩
但是想到要去外面走
那時候大學的想像是太貴了
這個運動不可能打得起
但是出社會之後就發現
其實它並不是一個特別貴的運動
它貴在哪
它貴在你要有那個時間可以在那邊打
貴在時間
好 非常感謝你的推薦
或許以後友誼會接觸到
下面一位
聲聲不息 猛攻大大安
突然想知道
你有沒有興趣踏進Hi-Fi的世界
也是因為聽到您研究紅酒等等
通常有這個聯想
個人覺得是集科技跟玄學於一聲
又有接近無上限的體驗
很想知道你研究之後的看法等等
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕